[Music]
there's never been a black cop in this
city we think you might be the man to
open things up around here oh this is
Ron Stallworth called
Who am I speaking with this is David
Duke Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux Klan
that David dude God last time I checked
what can I do for it well since you
asked I hate blacks
I hate Jews Mexicans and Irish Italians
and Chinese but my mouth to God's ears I
really hate those black brats and anyone
else really that doesn't have pure white
Aryan blood running through their veins
I'm happy to be talking about true white
American god bless white America the KKK
is planning an attack how do you propose
to make this investigation well
establish contact over the phone we'll
need a white officer to play me when
they meet face to face before the white
race Ron oh no no
so they becomes a combine Ron Staller
can you do that with the right white man
we can do anything
[Music]
where's the last time they let a rookie
lead an investigation oh that's right
never okay become his friend
let's get invited back what kind of
stuff you guys know cross burnings
marches this is fixed it'll be a big
year for us that's too many questions
you undercover or something
tonight they've organized to fight
racism are you down for the liberation
of black people power to the people all
power to all the people that's right
system for you it's a crusade for me
it's a job you're Jewish that hatred
doesn't that piss you off
you're taking this Jew lie detector test
why are you acting like you ain't got
skin in the game I'm telling you a Wars
at Commons Knights of the Ku Klux Klan
that's us
Stallworth brothers voted no this is a
plan you know I would have taken this
love
you